hello and welcome to this video new euro
bite okay Oh or the King's gambit okay
let's have some funny over there five
the enolate counter gambit it's not
exactly the same as response to the
Kings gambit but certainly one of the
more entertaining ones okay what now go
into is seven step to move let's do that
sometimes they just take on c6 in this
kind of situation go G form typical
Kings Kings gambit insanity but it might
be the way to go if I just know it just
gives me that I cannot Castle Queen c5
check so nice one that position to be
honest looks already suspicious to me
for white
k castles is to a queen before then
Bishop c5 just want to make cancelling
more difficult for him that's nice I
didn't see that hahahaha I just
blundered this Oh God hmm okay maybe
it's not such a big deal
plenty of activity I think with Bishop
c5 and so on so Bishop c5 he goes
between 8-4 i guess ii III is an
interesting move here let's do that
it takes it there's a rube t1 route you
one coming look do you one should win
the look or is there a big trick is also
nitey forward this is not as convincing
maybe it is as convincing so we look
rope there check ok I mean let's see is
there anything better here even 94 I
mean night takes a queen takes c3 is
cute but there's all kinds of checks and
so on coming Bishop c5 as an interesting
one but ok I let's take a look I don't
see any compensation here and 20 x III
now is some things that is a threat I
think it will take c3 494 made no Bishop
is six though maybe he would be able to
talk himself out of this now don't don't
need fancy museum
oopsie five checky actually wins the
rook so maybe this for h4
also threatening made h4 check king of
294 check night XD for Queenie one made
funny um but Bishop e7 huh 94 is made so
and g5 should also be made somehow just
with with checks tings tings yeah came
officially 70 scooter 94 is pretty
strong threat
check
check okay so let's see how to how to
win this now
check I do see the mid-90 three King g6
fancier made so maybe just have to win
the Queen okay let's just win the Queen
white resigns yeah only in the King's
gambit you get such Becky positions ok
so I don't really know what's best
against this line and one point they
they had d3 but well and I cannot really
tell him I'm just playing this for fun
in with Jess there's this and yeah maybe
you have to do something like g4 it
doesn't feel like a good position if i
get if i get in the way it went I think
here I'm just better and the engine
grease gives me a pretty big advantage
maybe just castles here yeah castles is
it's not too late anyway a long long now
he is pretty it simply blundered a seven
but it wasn't a clear business at all
kappa should be three looks very normal
ok now we went here who came so the
computer says d4 and white is clearly
better
till not an easy move to play that I
kind of see the point now if I take now
he will exchange and play a CAPTCHA only
three no I don't have a good move him
hmm it's strong yeah this is giving the
rook well actually actually a I could
have made it it was Quincy 30 it's bad
how long did she actually took over him
this is this is jade so check checkmate
I saw the idea a little bit later but
not inside him it was just too tempting
too tempting to take the rukia's check
check check check I rooke g2 is made ok
check and checkmate this one ok taking
the Queen isn't so bad is bad either you
will be mating a yeah very soonish ok
that was a funny game at least thanks
for watching